From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Sarah Koenig sitting in for Ira Glass, who's off this week. To begin in the show we wanted Julie Snyder, our senior producer, and her husband, Jeff Melman, to tell the story about something that happened with Julie's hairdresser. So they came into the studio.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是莎拉·柯尼格，代班主持本周不在的艾拉·格拉斯。节目开始，我们想让高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德和她的丈夫杰夫·梅尔曼讲讲她发型师身上发生的事。于是他们来到了演播室。
OK, I'm here. You're there and he's there.
好了，我在这儿。你在那儿，他也在那儿。
And before we got into the hairdresser story, Julie was trying to figure out a clever way to introduce the fact that Ira was away. She thought maybe we could do a little skit to tell people that. So she fed Jeff this line.
在讲发型师的故事之前，朱莉一直在想一个巧妙的方法来介绍艾拉不在的事实。她觉得也许我们可以演个小短剧告诉大家。于是她给了杰夫这句台词。
Oh, you're supposed to say, so where is Ira, right now.
哦，你应该说，那么艾拉现在在哪儿呢。
Right now? So where is Ira?
现在？那么艾拉在哪儿呢？
No, not like that.
不，不是那样。
Note how quickly she shoots him down, doesn't even wait a polite second to pretend to consider whether that was any good. That's why she's the senior producer. She keeps at him.
注意她拒绝他的速度有多快，连客气一下假装考虑一下是不是说得好都不等。这就是她成为高级制作人的原因。她一直催着他。
So where is Ira?
那么艾拉在哪儿呢？
So where is Ira? Let me do it again. I told you, this is--
那么艾拉在哪儿呢？让我再来一次。我告诉过你，这——
More natural.
更自然一点。
I told you, this is not my thing.
我告诉过你，这不是我擅长的。
So where is Ira?
那么艾拉在哪儿呢？
See.
你看。
Do it just the way Sarah just said it.
就照莎拉刚才说的那样做。
This is going to affect our marriage.
这会影响我们的婚姻的。
Jeff likes to say that, but in fact this will not affect their marriage. I've known them for a long time, and, as the President likes to say, the State of the Union is strong.
杰夫喜欢这么说，但事实上这不会影响他们的婚姻。我认识他们很久了，正如总统常说的，国情很稳固。
OK, so we're here to tell you this story, so we'll start in on telling you the story.
好的，我们来这儿是为了告诉你们这个故事，所以我们开始讲故事了。
The story is a gossip story. That's what our show's about today, gossip. And it starts, like any classic of the genre, in a hair salon.
这是一个关于八卦的故事。这就是我们今天节目的主题，八卦。它像所有经典八卦一样，始于一家美发沙龙。
First of all, what you need to know Sarah, is that my hair color is not natural.
首先，莎拉，你需要知道的是，我的发色不是天生的。
Stop. Julie visits her colorist every six to eight weeks. They've struck up a friendship.
停。朱莉每六到八周会去见一次她的调色师。她们已经建立了友谊。
You know, how are you, how are your kids, blah, blah, blah, where are you living, what are you doing, and stuff like that. And at one point, she started telling me-- I don't know if she was broken up with her boyfriend or they were on a break, but she was starting something on the side, she told me, with a guy who worked at a restaurant in our town. And she started describing him to me, and I knew who she was talking about. I was like, oh yeah, that guy. He's the best looking guy that works there. And it sounded all very exciting. And then like the next time, like six to
eight weeks later, I asked how that was going. And by then, it wasn't going as well. But she also was like, when I asked her about it, she was kind of like, oh, shh, shh, shh. And sort of admonished me for asking about it in a normal tone of voice. And then, she waits until it there's like nobody else around, and then kneels down very quietly next to me, and was just like, it's just that I don't really like people knowing my business.
你知道，你好吗，你的孩子怎么样，巴拉巴拉，你住哪儿，在做什么，诸如此类。有一次，她开始告诉我——我不知道她是和男朋友分手了还是正在冷静期，但她说她开始和一个在镇上餐馆工作的男人交往。她开始向我描述他，我就知道她在说谁了。我就说，噢，是啊，那个家伙。他是那儿长得最帅的员工。听起来非常令人兴奋。然后就像下一次，大概六到八周后，我问进展如何。那时，情况不太好了。但当我问她的时候，她就像是，噢，嘘，嘘，嘘。她因为我用正常的音量询问而告诫我。然后，她等到周围没人的时候，静静地跪在我身边，说，只是我真的不喜欢别人知道我的私事。
So then Julie's hairdresser goes on to tell her some kind of embarrassing stories about the guy. And how she's not that into him any more. She might break it off, maybe go back to the original boyfriend. And Julie goes home and tells all of this to Jeff, which she figures is a dead-end for this top-secret information. He's unconnected. He doesn't know the hairdresser. There's no reason he'd repeat it. The gossip is safely stored within the walls of their kitchen.
然后朱莉的发型师继续跟她讲了一些关于那个男人的尴尬事。以及她对他没那么感兴趣了。她可能会分手，也许会回到原来的男朋友身边。朱莉回家后把这一切告诉了杰夫，她认为这对于这种绝密信息来说是死胡同。他没有任何联系。他不认识那个发型师。他没理由会重提此事。这个八卦被安全地锁在他们厨房的墙壁之内。
So fast forward to the neighborhood Christmas party. Julie stays home with one kid, but Jeff takes their daughter to the party. He's not having a good time. It's a lot of small talk with people he doesn't know. It's a little awkward. So using his six-year-old to escape, he wanders upstairs.
时间快进到社区圣诞派对。朱莉和一个孩子留在家里，但杰夫带着他们的女儿去参加派对。他玩得不开心。他必须和不认识的人进行很多寒暄。这有点尴尬。于是他利用六岁的女儿作为逃避的借口，溜到了楼上。
We were like in the kid's bedroom. Where a bunch of kids were, and they were all like playing, like throwing stuffed animals around. That's where I was hanging out. No because my daughter needed me to be there, but because I'm not a big party guy. So I don't know. So somehow I overheard these women talking.
我们就像是在孩子的卧室里。那儿有一群孩子，他们都在玩，把毛绒玩具扔来扔去。我就在那儿待着。不是因为我女儿需要我在那儿，而是因为我不擅长交际。所以我不知道。所以不知怎的，我无意中听到了那些女人的谈话。
Jeff overhears the women say their sister works at the salon that Julie goes to. So he chimes in, makes a connection.
杰夫无意中听到那些女人说她们的姐妹就在朱莉去的那家沙龙工作。于是他插了话，建立起了联系。
I think I said something like, did you know about the relationship with the guy in the restaurant or something like that. I think I jumped right in.
我想我说了类似这样的话，你们知道她在餐馆里和那个男人的关系吗？之类的。我想我直接就说了。
In fact, they knew nothing about the guy in the restaurant. But they wanted to know everything.
事实上，她们对餐馆里的那个男人一无所知。但她们想了解一切。
And then of course, they were just full of joy. They were so eager to hear more. I mean, I told them everything that I knew. I think, I made up some stuff maybe, possibly. Yeah, the more I told them, the more interested they were in me, and the--
然后当然，她们充满了喜悦。她们非常渴望听到更多。我是说，我知道的一切都告诉她们了。我想，我可能还编造了一些东西，也许吧。是的，我说得越多，她们就越对我感兴趣，而且——
[LAUGHING] Oh, God.
[笑声] 噢，天哪。
--they were enjoying me.
——她们很享受和我交谈。
Oh, my God.
噢，天哪。
I couldn't stop. I can honestly say, at no point during the conversation, like while I was at the party, did I think that what I was doing was not OK. Like it never felt like, oh, I should stop. It was great. I mean, they were filling my cup--
我停不下来。我可以诚实地说，在派对期间的谈话中，我从未觉得我做的事情有什么不对。就像从来没觉得，噢，我该停下来了。那感觉太棒了。我是说，她们在填满我的杯子——
[LAUGHING] Oh, God.
[笑声] 噢，天哪。
--lighting my cigarette for me. It was like that. I mean, I just spilled it all. And then, like I said, when I left, I was excited to go tell Julie about it. Somehow I though that she would be as excited as I was.
——为我点烟。就是那种感觉。我是说，我全盘托出了。然后，就像我说的，当我离开时，我很兴奋地去告诉朱莉。我总觉得她会像我一样兴奋。
And I was just like, wait. What? Jeff thought this was no big deal at all. And I was like, did the sisters know? And he was like, no, they didn't know. They had no idea. I just couldn't believe, why would you do that? Why would you tell them that? This is a really, really, big deal.
而我就是，等等。什么？杰夫觉得这根本没什么大不了。我就说，那姐妹们知道吗？他说是的，她们不知道。她们完全不知道。我简直不敢相信，你为什么要那么做？你为什么要告诉她们？这真的是非常、非常严重的事情。
Julie had seen the chess pieces lineup immediately. Her colorist has three sisters. They're close, which means if they didn't know about the cheating, the sister, very pointedly, did not want them to know, didn't want their judgment. And she also knew that her colorist would quickly figure out that it was Julie who blabbed to Jeff, who blabbed to the sisters. Which is exactly what happened. And this has stumped Julie ever since, why Jeff would be so clueless? Jeff's defense is that he doesn't have Julie's talent for understanding the contours of gossip. He can't feel the significance of secrets the way she does. He can't always figure out their weight and value and danger. It's a real disability.
朱莉一眼就看出了棋局。她的调色师有三个姐妹。她们关系密切，这意味着如果她们不知道出轨的事，那么那个姐妹肯定非常刻意地不想让她们知道，不想受到她们的评判。她也知道她的调色师很快就会发现是朱莉告诉了杰夫，杰夫又告诉了姐妹们。而这正是发生的。这让朱莉一直很困惑，为什么杰夫会如此迟钝？杰夫的辩护是，他没有朱莉那种理解八卦脉络的天赋。他无法像她那样感受到秘密的重要性。他无法总是搞清楚它们的重量、价值和危险。这真是个缺陷。
I, honestly, I swear, when I got home from the party I was very excited to tell Julie about this. Somehow, it felt like I had done good. For some reason I thought Julie would be very pleased with me.
我，老实说，我发誓，当我从派对回家时，我非常兴奋地告诉朱莉这件事。不知怎的，我觉得我做得很好。出于某种原因，我以为朱莉会对我感到非常高兴。
You were like a cat bringing home a dead mouse for her to lay at her feet.
你就好像是一只给主人叼回死老鼠放在她脚边的猫。
I sort of thought of it as like a family victory, like we really scored at this party.
我把它看作是一种家庭胜利，好像我们在派对上大获全胜。
So I've read a little bit of like wonky, academic stuff about gossip just in the last week, and there's various definitions or whatever. But this one academic from Yale wrote this whole book in the '80s. And one of the things she posits, actually, is that gossip is-- there's extremes of gossip which are really bad, like tearing somebody's character apart, or very malicious gossip, obviously that no one condones. But that gossip itself is a way of like making an emotional connection with people around you. And super important and really good. And that it carries an erotic power in fact. That there's something erotic in having access to information and being the one to pass something exciting on to somebody else. And I'm wondering.
所以我在过去的一周里读了一些关于八卦的深奥的学术文章，有各种定义之类的。但一位耶鲁大学的学者在80年代写了整本书。实际上，她提出的观点之一是，八卦——八卦有极端的情况，非常糟糕，比如毁坏某人的名声，或者非常恶意的八卦，显然那是没人赞同的。但八卦本身是一种与周围人建立情感联系的方式。它非常重要且非常有益。它甚至带有某种色情的力量。事实上，获得信息并成为将一些令人兴奋的事情传递给别人的人，其中有某种色情意味。我在想。
Well, I do have a lot of erotic power, that's true.
嗯，我确实有很强的色情力量，这是真的。
I could tell that.
我能看出来。
I think that's very interesting. I mean, maybe some of that is tied up in it. This is really going to affect my marriage by the way.
我觉得这很有意思。我是说，也许其中一部分与之有关。顺便说一句，这真的会影响我的婚姻。
The fact is, now that I hear you talk about it now, it's sweet that you just loved them listening to you and laughing.
事实是，现在听你这么说，想到你那么喜欢她们听你说话并为你发笑，真的很可爱。
The erotic power?
那色情力量？
I actually find the erotic power part to be sort of sweet.
我其实觉得色情力量那部分有点可爱。
It almost makes me feel like I would do it again.
这甚至让我觉得我会再做一次。
Oh.
噢。
No, I'm just kidding.
不，我开玩笑的。
We all gossip, but we don't always understand its power, its erotic power, if you will. On today's show we've got gossip, gossip, and more gossip. Stories, where yes, the gossip can be dangerous and slanderous but also a force for good. We've got rampant gossip on another continent. And a short story about when gossipers go pro. If you want to hear what we'ver heard, stay with us.
我们都八卦，但我们并不总是理解它的力量，如果你愿意的话，它的色情力量。在今天的节目中，我们有八卦、八卦，还是八卦。有些故事，是的，八卦可能是危险和诽谤性的，但也可以是一种善的力量。我们在另一个大陆上听到了猖獗的八卦。还有一个关于八卦者何时成为职业人士的短篇故事。如果你想听听我们所听到的，请留下来。
Part of what makes gossip gossip is that you're not supposed to do it. It's in the Bible. It's in the Koran. Jewish law prohibits it. It's considered sinful. But sometimes you have to. That's true in Malawi, in southeast Africa, for instance. There gossiping is, of course, frowned upon, but not gossiping can be even worse. Hazel Namadingo is from Malawi. She's 26, and she went to college in Malawi, at a place called Chancellor College, where gossip wasn't just common, it was organized.
八卦之所以成为八卦，部分原因是你不应该这样做。圣经里有，古兰经里也有。犹太法律禁止它。它被认为是罪恶的。但有时你必须这样做。例如，在非洲东南部的马拉维，情况确实如此。在那里，八卦当然是不受赞成的，但不八卦可能会更糟。黑兹尔·纳马丁戈来自马拉维。她26岁，在马拉维的一所大学，也就是钱塞勒学院上过大学，在那里八卦不仅常见，而且是有组织的。
There was some kind of board where people posted gossips.
有一种公告板，人们会在上面张贴八卦。
It was a bulletin board, in fact, in the college's main library.
事实上，那是学院主图书馆里的一个公告栏。
So every morning people would rush to that board to see the latest thing that has happened around campus.
所以每天早上，人们都会冲向那个公告栏，看看校园里发生的最新消息。
What kind of gossip?
什么样的八卦？
What kind of gossip? That's a stupid question if I do say so myself. Because, really, there's only one kind of gossip you'd rush to see on the bulletin board every morning. And that's, of course, gossip about sex. And I guess this is a good place for a listener warning that this story does discuss sex and birth control. Not graphically, at all, but just the existence of it. So if you're listening with kids, you might want to know that.
什么样的八卦？如果我可以这么说的话，这是一个愚蠢的问题。因为，真的，你每天早上冲向公告栏只想看一种八卦。那就是，关于性的八卦。我想这对听众来说是一个很好的提醒，这个故事确实会讨论性和节育。一点也不露骨，只是讨论它们的存在。所以如果你和孩子们一起收听，你可能想知道这一点。
Sex, as any gossiper knows, is the mother of all good gossip. If you made a pie chart of gossip topics, sex would have to be half the pie, maybe even 3/4. The same was certainly true at Chancellor College.
正如任何八卦者所知，性是所有好八卦的源头。如果你做一张八卦主题的饼图，性肯定占一半，甚至四分之三。这在钱塞勒学院绝对是真的。
It ranged from maybe a guy being caught in the girl's hostel--
范围从一个男人在女生宿舍被抓到——
A hostel is like a dorm.
宿舍就是宿舍。
--up to a girl getting grades for having sex with a lecturer.
——到女生通过与讲师发生性关系来获取成绩。
And this would be on this public bulletin board, where everyone can read it?
而这会出现在公共公告栏上，每个人都能看到？
Yeah.
是的。
And the university new about it?
大学知道这件事吗？
Yeah, it knew, but they had no control over it whatsoever.
是的，它知道，但它对此完全无法控制。
The bulletin board did eventually stop, but the gossip didn't. And it's not like it went underground.
公告板最终停止了，但八卦并没有。而且它并没有转入地下。
It was now being printed in newspapers.
它现在被印在报纸上了。
In like a campus newspaper you mean?
你是说校园报纸吗？
So in my time, we had several newspapers. We had a school newspaper, which was OK. It printed a lot of stuff that you can read and benefit from. But then there was this other newspaper, which a group of boys and girls would print, and it was just pure gossip from first page to the last page. It had names, but the foremost one was just The Tabloid. I think it was called that.
在我那个时候，我们有好几份报纸。我们有一份校报，还不错。它印了很多你可以阅读并从中受益的内容。但还有另一份报纸，由一群男生和女生印刷，从头到尾全是八卦。上面有名字，但最出名的一份只是叫“小报”。我想是那个名字。
Hazel says The Tabloid quote, "Gave too much detail to things that you would want to keep secret." Which is pretty much the best definition of a gossip rag that I've ever heard. For anyone who's gone to college, or to high school, or, for that matter, simply existed in any kind of fornicating society, the stories in The Tabloid are probably familiar. Two people got together and had sex, discuss.
黑兹尔说“小报”引用：“对于那些你想要保密的事情，给予了太多的细节。”这几乎是我听过的对八卦小报最好的定义。对于任何上过大学或高中，或者仅仅生活在任何一种有性行为的社会中的人来说，小报上的故事可能都很熟悉。两个人在一起发生了性关系，讨论一下。
But in Malawi, I'm going to venture to say, that this kind of gossip, not to put to fine a point on it, is a matter of life and death. Because in Malawi a lot of people have HIV and AIDS, and so figuring out who is safe to go out with is a serious concern.
但在马拉维，我敢说，这种八卦，说得委婉一点，是关乎生死的。因为在马拉维，很多人患有艾滋病，所以弄清楚谁可以安全交往是一个严重的担忧。
Hazel works for an American run research project that's interested in how AIDS is changing the way young people in Malawi make decisions about family planning, about who to marry, how many kids to have. She supervises a team of researchers who interview young people three times a year to see, among other things, how their love lives have changed, what decisions they've made about their relationships and why. And AIDS is central to all this. In Malawi everyone knows someone who's got it.
黑兹尔为一个美国研究项目工作，该项目对艾滋病如何改变马拉维年轻人关于计划生育、结婚对象以及生育数量的决定很感兴趣。她主管一个研究团队，每年三次采访年轻人，查看他们的爱情生活发生了什么变化，他们对自己的关系做了什么决定，以及为什么，等等。而艾滋病是这一切的核心。在马拉维，每个人都认识感染了艾滋病的人。
How many people would you say you know or know of, who are positive?
你会说你认识或听说过多少艾滋病阳性的人？
In my life, for sure, I know three. And these are all my relatives. Yeah, I know my brother is positive. I know my niece is positive. I know my brother's wife is positive. That's for sure. But for some people I just meet in my neighborhood or work with, I can't really say that I know what they're positive, maybe suspect.
在我的生活中，肯定有三个。而且他们都是我的亲戚。是的，我知道我弟弟是阳性。我知道我侄女是阳性。我知道我弟媳是阳性。这肯定是。但对于我邻居或同事中遇到的一些人，我不能真的说我知道他们是阳性，也许是怀疑。
What about the second category, sort of, you've heard around town?
那第二类呢，就是你在城里听说的那些？
A lot, like they can reach up to 50.
很多，可能高达50个。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Hazel herself is married now, and has a newborn baby. But she says AIDS was a constant topic with her friends. Before they'd date someone, they'd ask around about them, and make their decision based on the gossip. It's so common to discuss whether someone's got the virus that there's shorthand for it.
黑兹尔本人现在已经结婚，并且有个刚出生的宝宝。但她说艾滋病是她和朋友们讨论的永恒话题。在和某人约会之前，她们会到处打听他们，并根据八卦做出决定。讨论某人是否患有病毒是如此普遍，以至于有专门的简称。
We have our own terms that we use to name someone who has AIDS, or who is on ARVs.
我们有自己的术语来指代那些患有艾滋病，或者正在服用抗逆转录病毒药物的人。
ARVs stands for antiretrovirals, the medication that some people with HIV take.
ARVs代表抗逆转录病毒药物，即某些艾滋病毒感染者服用的药物。
So when you want to go out with a person, and your friends will say no. That one is poison. Like the person is poison, you can't go near him. Or sometimes we call or we name that person, oh, that one is using units.
所以当你想要和一个这样的人约会时，你的朋友会说不。那个人是毒药。就像那个人是毒药，你不能靠近他。或者有时我们称呼或命名那个人，噢，那个人正在使用“单位”。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
That means-- you know, in Malawi, the mobile phones that we have?
那意味着——你知道，在马拉维，我们拥有的移动电话吗？
This one's a little complicated. In Malawi, to use a mobile phone, you have to buy a card with phone units on it. And once you use them up, you have to buy more to buy more time. So if a person is said to be on units, that's slang for taking ARVs. They have to top-up on the medication every single day to buy more time. In Malawi, just like in the US, AIDS testing is confidential. So really people are usually guessing about who's infected and who isn't. But where Hazel lives secrets get around pretty fast. For instance, if you go to the hospital for malaria testing at the laboratory, which isn't all that uncommon--
这一点有点复杂。在马拉维，要使用移动电话，你必须购买带有电话单位的卡。一旦用完，你必须购买更多来获得更多时间。所以如果一个人被称为在使用“单位”，那就是正在服用ARVs的俚语。他们必须每天补充药物来购买更多时间。在马拉维，就像在美国一样，艾滋病检测是保密的。所以人们通常是在猜测谁被感染了，谁没有。但黑兹尔居住的地方，秘密传得非常快。例如，如果你去医院在实验室进行疟疾检测，这并不罕见——
Right next, after they-- laboratory-- there is this room where it's written that-- ARVs. So when you see people going there, queuing on the line towards the ARVs door, you conclude that they are positive. So these are some of the ways how people come up with kind of gossip that so and so is positive, so and so is on ARVs.
就在那之后，实验室旁边有一个房间，写着——ARVs。所以当你看到人们去那里，在通往ARVs门的队伍里排队时，你就会推断他们是阳性。所以这些就是人们得出某人是阳性，某人正在服用ARVs这种八卦的一些方式。
ARVs are helping a lot of infected people in Malawi live a lot longer, but they also complicate gossip. If a girl is beautiful, for example, it doesn't necessarily help her chances of finding a partner partly because of ARVs.
ARVs正在帮助马拉维许多感染者活得更久，但它们也使八卦变得复杂。例如，如果一个女孩很漂亮，这并不一定能增加她找到伴侣的机会，部分原因就是ARVs。
Like if you see someone who is, maybe, a little bit fat--
比如你看到某人，也许，稍微有点胖——
Remember girls, this is Africa, where a little bit fat is good.
记住女孩们，这是非洲，在那里稍微有点胖是好事。
Or maybe her skin is so smooth, some people like put questions behind that. They don't think this person is normal. Like they have the virus.
或者也许她的皮肤非常光滑，有些人会在那后面打问号。他们不认为这个人是正常的。就像他们有病毒一样。
Because they look too good?
因为她们看起来太好了？
Yeah, they look too good.
是的，她们看起来太好了。
Because the ARVs can make your skin smooth?
因为ARVs会让皮肤变光滑？
Yeah, that's what most people say. That's the explanation that is going around right now.
是的，大多数人这么说。这就是现在流传的解释。
Hazel herself happens to be uncommonly beautiful, and she's been the subject of rumors too. But she says her job saves her from the worst of it. Her neighbors know that her work is connected to a white person, which means she's probably well paid in dollars, and so can afford to take care of herself and wear nice clothes. There's an explanation for her beauty. But if you're a girl without a job, who looks good and dresses expensively, then you're suspect. Because that means you must be sleeping around, getting money from men. Which means you could be infected.
黑兹尔本人恰好非常漂亮，她也曾是谣言的主角。但她说她的工作使她免受了最坏的影响。她的邻居知道她的工作与一个白人有关，这意味着她可能收入丰厚，因此有能力照顾好自己并穿漂亮的衣服。对她的美貌有解释。但如果你是一个没有工作的女孩，看起来很好且打扮昂贵，那你就是被怀疑的对象。因为那意味着你一定在到处乱搞，从男人那里拿钱。这意味着你可能被感染了。
Mostly the beautiful ones are a cause of alarm. If you're not so attractive you're safe.
大部分漂亮的女孩都会引起警惕。如果你没那么有吸引力，你就安全了。
Safe from what? You're safe to have sex with?
安全免于什么？你是安全的可以发生性关系吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You have to be a bit careful about AIDS gossip though. Hazel told me you can get taken to court. That is, someone can bring a case against you to the local chief if you accuse them of having AIDS. And if you don't have proof, which almost no one does, you can get fined.
不过关于艾滋病的八卦你必须有点小心。黑兹尔告诉我，你可能会被带上法庭。也就是说，如果你指责某人患有艾滋病，有人可以向当地酋长提起诉讼。如果你没有证据，几乎没人有证据，你可能会被罚款。
It's understandable, being accused of having AIDS when you don't, that's a rumor that's a very, very hard to shake. And it can ruin your life. In Malawi, Hazel says, it's among the top three things you don't want to be accused of. The other two are being a witch and practising satanism. So while no one exactly condones gossiping where Hazel lives, everyone knows that sometimes it's required.
这是可以理解的，被指责患有艾滋病，如果你没有，那是一个非常、非常难以消除的谣言。它会毁了你的生活。在马拉维，黑兹尔说，这是你不希望被指责的三大罪状之一。另外两个是当巫婆和从事撒旦崇拜。所以虽然在黑兹尔居住的地方没有人确切地赞同八卦，但每个人都知道有时它是必要的。
Take the case of this one neighbor of Hazel's, a young woman. She used to be good looking, but then she lost a lot of weight. Rumors started that she had AIDS, and that she was going out with a couple of men in town. When the gossip got back to her, she started keeping to herself, not really leaving the house or doing the normal things she liked to do. Until, finally, she went to the hospital and got on ARVs, saved herself. But the danger for the men in town is that now she doesn't look like she has AIDS at all. Her disease is hidden. She's a one-woman public health threat.
以黑兹尔的一位邻居，一位年轻女性为例。她曾经很好看，但后来体重减轻了很多。谣言开始说她患有艾滋病，并且她正和城里的几个男人交往。当八卦传回她耳中时，她开始足不出户，不再离开房子或做她喜欢的正常事情。直到最后，她去医院开始服用ARVs，救了自己。但城里的男人们面临的危险是，现在她看起来一点也不像患有艾滋病。她的疾病被隐藏了。她是一个人的公共卫生威胁。
The thing is, when men see her now, like she's healthy. She got back a little bit of weight, and you really can't tell that she has AIDS. So I would say it's really tricky. Like, to say, in this way is gossip good for her, was it good for the society? Was it bad for her, was it bad for the society? But, I would still say for her it was good, because it made her make that decision, which she wouldn't have made if people weren't gossiping about her. But for many in our society, I think, it's not good. Because now she's healthy and more attractive than she was.
问题是，现在当男人看到她时，她很健康。她恢复了一些体重，你真的看不出她患有艾滋病。所以我不得不说这真的很棘手。就像是，说，在某种方式上这种八卦对她有好处，对社会有好处吗？这对她不好，对社会不好吗？但是，我仍然会说这对她有好处，因为它促使她做出了那个决定，如果人们没有议论她，她是不会做出的。但对于我们社会中的许多人来说，我认为，这不是好事。因为现在她很健康，比以前更有吸引力。
So if someone new came to the neighborhood, maybe someone you liked, or became friends with her, or was a relative and said, "oh, look at your attractive neighbor. I think I would like to ask her out." Would you gossip and say, "look, I know she looks good, but she's got the virus, you should know that." Or do you feel like you can't gossip that way, because it's too, possibly, harmful for her? What's the right thing to do?
所以如果有人搬到社区，也许是你喜欢的人，或者成为了她的朋友，或者是一个亲戚说，“噢，看你那个有吸引力的邻居。我想我想约她出去。”你会八卦说，“看，我知道她看起来很好，但她有病毒，你应该知道这一点。”还是你觉得你不能那样八卦，因为它太，可能，对她有害了？什么是正确的做法？
I think I'll gossip because of seeing the way she looked before. Yeah, I'll tell my share of the gossip that I've heard.
我想我会八卦，因为我看到了她以前的样子。是的，我会告诉别人我听到的八卦。
You could call it gossiping. Or you could call it using your social network to educate those around you about how AIDS works and how to avoid getting it. That's what a sociologist named Susan Watkins would call it. Because what Hazel's been doing all this time with her friends and family, all the gossiping, that is the basis for a huge research project.
你可以称之为八卦。或者你可以称之为利用你的社交网络来教育周围的人关于艾滋病是如何运作的以及如何避免感染它。这就是社会学家苏珊·沃特金斯所说的。因为黑兹尔一直和她的朋友与家人所做的，所有的八卦，那是一个庞大研究项目的基础。
Watkins, along with colleagues and grad students, has spent more than 10 years looking at how people's social interactions, including their gossip, shape their attitudes about AIDS, first in Kenya then Malawi. She spends about two months a year in Africa. She was initially researching family planning, but her field work kept getting interrupted by funerals.
沃特金斯和她的同事以及研究生们花了10多年时间研究人们的社交互动，包括他们的八卦，如何塑造他们对艾滋病的态度，首先是在肯尼亚，然后是马拉维。她每年在非洲待大约两个月。她最初研究计划生育，但她的田野工作不断被葬礼打断。
Sometimes local people were going to three or four a week of people who died of AIDS. So she switched to focus on AIDS. Watkins started researching people's sexual behavior the way most sociologists do, with surveys. But the information respondents were giving her wasn't all that accurate.
有时当地人一周要参加三到四次死于艾滋病的人的葬礼。所以她转向关注艾滋病。沃特金斯开始像大多数社会学家那样通过调查来研究人们的性行为。但受访者提供的信息并不那么准确。
After all, she was an outsider. A stranger holding a clipboard. People didn't want to tell her all the details of their sex lives. To figure out what rural Malawians really thought, Watkins needed to hear what they said to each other when she wasn't around. She needed to eavesdrop. So she hired local people she knew to keep journals.
毕竟，她是个外来者。一个拿着剪贴板的陌生人。人们不想告诉她性生活的全部细节。为了弄清楚农村马拉维人真正的想法，沃特金斯需要听听他们在她不在场时彼此说些什么。她需要窃听。于是她雇佣了她认识的当地人写日记。
So I just said, why don't you just listen. Wherever you go, in the course of your daily life, if you hear anybody talking about AIDS just listen and then go home later in the evening and write it down. And write it down as specifically as you can in exactly the words that they used.
所以我只是说，为什么你不去听呢。无论你去哪里，在你的日常生活中，如果你听到任何人谈论艾滋病，只要去听，然后在晚上回家后写下来。并尽可能具体地按照他们使用的确切词语写下来。
She ended up with thousands and thousands of pages of preserved public gossip written by hand in school notebooks and spanning more than a decade. Conversations at markets, funerals, bars, churches, water wells. And the contents were surprising. The journals bucked much of the conventional wisdom about how rural Malawians were dealing with the AIDS epidemic on the ground.
她最终获得了成千上万页的手写公共八卦，记录在学校笔记本上，跨越了十多年。在市场、葬礼、酒吧、教堂、水井处的谈话。内容令人惊讶。这些日记推翻了许多关于农村马拉维人如何在当地应对艾滋病流行的传统观念。
I realized that what these conversations, these gossip that was going on as people talk to each other about, did you see so and so is looking thin? Or did you see so and so? She's got shingles, and so she probably has AIDS? That there was just a lot of talk going on.
我意识到这些谈话，这些当人们彼此议论时的八卦，比如你看到某某看起来很瘦了吗？或者你看到某某了吗？她长了带状疱疹，所以她可能患有艾滋病？到处都有很多谈论。
And what was the prevailing wisdom among researchers about the way this was getting talked about or not talked about it in a place like rural Malawi?
那么在研究人员中，对于在像马拉维农村这样的地方这种事情是如何被谈论或不被谈论的主流智慧是什么？
Well, the prevailing view wasn't so much that of the researchers as that of the prevention community. Which would be the NGOs and the donors that were contributing money to have campaigns that would stem the tide of the epidemic. And their prevailing wisdom was that people don't talk about AIDS. It's a taboo topic. They don't talk about sex. And the Malawian elites, who work for the NGOs, said that as well. No our people don't talk about AIDS and don't talk about sex. But of course, we found out right away that they do. And they talk a lot. And they say very pertinent things to HIV prevention.
嗯，主流观点与其说是研究人员的，不如说是预防社区的。也就是那些捐款开展旨在遏制疫情蔓延的运动的非政府组织和捐助者。他们的主流智慧是人们不谈论艾滋病。这是一个禁忌话题。他们不谈论性。马拉维的精英们，那些为非政府组织工作的人，也这么说。不，我们的人民不谈论艾滋病，也不谈论性。但当然，我们很快发现他们确实谈论。而且他们谈论很多。并且他们说了非常切中要害的关于艾滋病毒预防的事情。
I have to say, having read a bunch of excerpts of the journals, that was the thing that surprised me immediately was they talk about sex all the time.
我必须说，读了那本日记的很多摘录，最让我立即惊讶的事情是他们一直在谈论性。
There was one wonderful conversation that I didn't send you, which was some guys in a trading center, just a little market area, standing around and talking. And one of them says, "Hey guys, I've got--"
有一个很棒的对话我没有发给你，是几个在贸易中心，也就是一个小市场区域的人站在那里聊天。其中一个人说，“嘿伙计们，我有——”
What he's got is a little too graphic for public radio. So let's just say, he's got an infection.
他有的东西对公共广播来说有点太露骨了。所以我们就说，他有感染了。
And the other guys say, "Well, what is it?" And he said, "Well, I don't know what it is." And they said, "Well, maybe your underwear is too tight" And he said, "No, my underwear isn't too tight." And then they said, "Well, maybe you've got a crack in your foreskin?" And he said, "No, I've looked at my foreskin, and I don't have a crack there." And then another guy chimed up and said, "You know, I think this might be gonorrhea. And if it is gonorrhea you better get it treated very quickly." And then somebody else jokingly said, "And, if you have gonorrhea, it's going to smell, and green flies are going to follow you." And then they all roared with laughter. And then they said, "Well, how do you think you got it?" And the guy said, "I don't know." He said, "Because I'm faithful to my girlfriend, and she's faithful to me." And at that point the guys laugh raucously and say, "Well, if that's the case, you couldn't possibly have what you have. So, if it's not you, it must be your girlfriend. So you ought to get rid of her. You ought to divorce her." And the guy says, "Oh, I can't divorce her." He says, "I've bought her already three pair of jeans at the PEP store in Blantyre, and two blouses, and a pair of sandals." So clearly, he had made an investment in this woman and was not yet ready to give her up. Unfortunately, we don't know the end.
其他伙计们说，“嗯，是什么？”他说，“嗯，我不知道是什么。”他们说，“嗯，也许你的内裤太紧了。”他说，“不，我的内裤不紧。”然后他们说，“嗯，也许你的包皮裂开了？”他说，“不，我看过我的包皮，我没有裂开。”然后另一个人插话说，“你知道，我想这可能是淋病。如果是淋病，你最好赶快治疗。”然后有人开玩笑说，“而且，如果你有淋病，会发出臭味，绿头蝇会跟着你。”然后他们都爆发出大笑。然后他们说，“嗯，你怎么认为你得上的？”那个人说，“我不知道。”他说，“因为我对我的女朋友忠诚，她也对我忠诚。”在这一点上，男人们大声嘲笑说，“嗯，如果是这样，你不可能有你所拥有的。所以，如果不是你，那一定是你女朋友。你应该甩了她。你应该离婚。”那个人说，“噢，我不能离婚。”他说，“我已经给她买了三条牛仔裤，是在布兰太尔的PEP商店，还有两件衬衫，和一双凉鞋。”所以很明显，他在这个女人身上做了投资，还没有准备好放弃她。不幸的是，我们不知道结局。
I think actually did read that one. And he also says, "No, I love her." He loves her.
我想实际上确实读过那个。他还说，“不，我爱她。”他爱她。
No, I love her. And anyway, I bought her all this stuff, exactly.
不，我爱她。总之，我给她买了所有这些东西，确实。
And he also says, if I remember, "Well, if she's got it, I already have it anyway. And if she has HIV, I've already got it then anyway, so what's the point of giving her up."
而且他还说，如果我没记错的话，“嗯，如果她有，反正我已经有了。如果她有艾滋病毒，那反正我已经有了，甩了她有什么意义。”
Exactly. That's a major misconception among Malawians-- and also, I've worked in Botswana and Swaziland and there I think it's all over-- that they vastly overestimate the probability of transmission in a single act of intercourse with an infected person. About 97% of our respondents said, it was certain or highly likely. And that's far from the truth. It's actually quite difficult to transmit HIV. But the people believe that. If you lie together, you die together, they say. So that allows this guy to say, well, there is no point in breaking up with her. And it also allows people to say, well, there's no point in my getting tested. I must be positive. I just had so many girlfriends.
确实。这是马拉维人中的一个重大误解——而且，我在博茨瓦纳和斯威士兰工作过，我想那里到处都是——他们严重高估了与感染者进行一次性行为的传播概率。大约97%的受访者说，这是肯定的或极有可能的。这与事实相去甚远。艾滋病毒实际上很难传播。但人们相信这一点。如果你躺在一起，你们就死在一起，他们说。所以这允许那个家伙说，好吧，甩了她毫无意义。这也允许人们说，好吧，我没必要去检测。我一定是阳性。我只是有过太多女朋友。
Oh, that's interesting. Because I was thinking maybe having that level of fear, like even one time and I'm doomed, might be kind of good. Like telling your kids, you'll get pregnant if you have sex even one time as a preventive thing. But you're saying, it actually can have the other affect too, which is making you blase.
噢，这很有意思。因为我以为那种程度的恐惧，比如哪怕只有一次我就死定了，可能还算件好事。就像告诉你的孩子，如果你有一次性行为就会怀孕，作为一种预防措施。但你说的是，它实际上也可能产生另一种效果，也就是让你变得冷漠。
Yeah, why would you use a condom. Nobody likes to use a condom. So if you're sure you're already infected, no way would you use a condom. Anyway, the women don't want to use condoms.
是的，为什么你要用避孕套。没人喜欢用避孕套。所以如果你确定你已经被感染了，无论如何你都不会用避孕套。总之，女人们也不想用避孕套。
Right, nobody seems to like the condoms. There's one quote that I love. That it said, using a condom oh, it's like eating sweets in a wrapper.
对，没人喜欢避孕套。我喜欢一句引用。就是说，用避孕套，噢，就像隔着包装纸吃糖果。
Yeah, that is all over Africa. And everybody tells it. They like slap their knee as if they are the first ones who ever told it. You can't eat sweets in a wrapper. And then they go ho, ho, ho. But it's absolutely all over the place.
是的，这在非洲随处可见。每个人都这么说。他们喜欢拍拍膝盖，好像他们是第一个说出来的人。你不能隔着包装纸吃糖果。然后他们哈哈大笑。但这绝对到处都是。
It's funny every time.
每次都很有趣。
Yeah, funny every time.
是的，每次都很有趣。
The other thing that I noticed reading them, or it just occurred to me, is that there seems to be a lot of gossip around, a lot of gossip around. And I'm thinking like, is that different from us? And then I thought, nah, probably not. But the level of it was really-- I was like, man alive. You really got to be careful what you say and do, I mean, because people are watching.
我阅读时注意到的另一件事，或者只是发生在我脑海里的是，似乎有很多八卦，有很多八卦。我在想，这和我们有什么不同吗？然后我想到，不，可能没有。但它的程度确实——我觉得，天哪。你真的必须小心你所说和所做的一切，我是说，因为人们在看着。
These are small communities with houses close to each other. They're mud huts with thatched roofs just like you see in National Geographic pictures of rural Africa. And, I think, because their houses are dark, there isn't electricity, people spend a lot of time outside. And that probably makes gossip happen more than if everybody is in their house with a half an acre yard around it. And they have to walk a lot of places to get water, to go to the market.
这些是小社区，房子彼此靠得很近。它们是泥屋，有茅草屋顶，就像你在《国家地理》关于非洲农村的图片里看到的一样。而且，我认为，因为它们的房子很暗，没有电，人们花很多时间在外面。这可能使得八卦比每个人都待在自己有半英亩院子的房子里发生得更多。而且他们必须步行很多地方去取水，去市场。
So there's just a lot of conversation all the time.
所以一直有很多谈话。
Yeah. They use these stories to launch discussions about how they can prevent themselves from getting AIDS. Saying, well, this person surely got AIDS because he said he would never use a condom. Whereas this person probably got AIDS through his wife, because she used to be married to so and so, who died of AIDS.
是的。他们利用这些故事来开启关于他们如何能够预防感染艾滋病的讨论。说，嗯，这个人肯定得了艾滋病，因为他说他永远不会用避孕套。而这个人可能通过他的妻子得了艾滋病，因为她曾经嫁给某某，那个人死于艾滋病。
Because gossiping about these people is really the only way to find that stuff out, right?
因为议论这些人确实是弄清楚那些事情的唯一途径，对吧？
Yeah, and in fact, they sometimes, when the men are gossiping or talking, they say, Timun died of AIDS, but he died because he didn't ask us. He didn't tell us he wanted to go with this partner and ask us for our opinion. If he had done that, we would have told him that she used to be married to Matthew, and Matthew worked in South Africa and came back with AIDS and died of it. So we would've told him, no, don't go for her. But he didn't ask us, so it's really his own fault. He knows better than that.
是的，实际上，有时，当男人们在八卦或交谈时，他们说，蒂蒙死于艾滋病，但他死是因为他没问我们。他没告诉我们他想和这个伴侣交往并征求我们的意见。如果他那样做了，我们会告诉他她曾经嫁给马修，而马修在南非工作并带着艾滋病回来，死于此病。所以我们会告诉他，不，不要去找她。但他没问我们，所以这真的是他自己的错。他知道得比这更好。
I was really struck by a one of Simon's entries from 2003. I just was really struck by-- so this woman walks by, and they just diagnose her on the fly, and then it launches this whole thing. And I'm wondering if you could just read that? It's your summary of what he's written, partly your summary, and partly his words, I think.
西蒙2003年的一篇日记让我印象深刻。我只是真的被——所以这个女人走过，他们就在现场诊断她，然后就引发了这一切。我在想你能不能读一下？这是你对他所写内容的总结，部分是你的总结，部分是他的话，我想。
The journalist has gone to the trading center, which is a small market, to buy soap for his wife and fish for lunch. He chats with a fish vendor, who is a friend of his, and then they both chat with a customer, who has sores on her face. Once she leaves they are joined by a neighboring vendor who had been listening. Together they diagnose the woman's condition as shingles, which they interpret as a symptom of AIDS.
记者去了贸易中心，那是一个小市场，去为他的妻子买肥皂，为午餐买鱼。他和一位鱼贩子聊天，那是他的朋友，然后他们都和一个脸上有疮的顾客聊天。她离开后，他们被一个一直在听的邻居摊贩加入。他们一起诊断那个女人的情况为带状疱疹，他们将其解释为艾滋病的症状。
They justify this diagnosis by providing a narrative of her sexual history. She's had four marriages all ending in divorce, because she was unfaithful. They then speculate as to whether her unfaithfulness was due to a need for money for her children or to lust. And why, in these days of the epidemic, any man would select her as a sexual partner. One man went on saying that she's on the way to the graveyard. This is not a time of playing with men by doing sex with them. Neither should men be playing with women by doing sex with them.
他们通过提供她性历史的叙述来证明这个诊断是合理的。她有四次婚姻，都以离婚告终，因为她不忠。他们然后猜测她的不忠是因为需要钱给孩子还是因为欲望。以及为什么，在疫情肆虐的今天，任何男人会选择她作为性伴侣。一个男人继续说她正在去墓地的路上。这不是通过做爱来玩弄男人的时候。男人也不应该通过做爱来玩弄女人。
We chatted and chatted, and finally we concluded by saying that, nowadays, it's better to just stop going with other sexual partners. It's better that whenever you want sex you should select a bar girl, because one cannot think of having plain sex with a bar girl. Everyone knows that any bar girl has AIDS, and, therefore, everyone having sex with her protects himself by using condoms. We chatted and chatted until I just bought the fish and left.
我们聊啊聊，最后我们得出结论说，如今，最好停止与其他性伴侣交往。最好是无论何时你想做爱，你应该选择一个酒吧女，因为没人会想到和酒吧女进行单纯的性行为。每个人都知道任何酒吧女都有艾滋病，因此，每个和她发生性关系的人都通过使用避孕套来保护自己。我们聊啊聊，直到我买了鱼离开了。
And just to be clear, when he says one cannot think of having plain sex with a bar girl, plain sex means sex without a condom?
为了清楚起见，当他说没人想到和酒吧女进行单纯的性行为时，单纯的性行为意味着没有避孕套的性行为？
With no-- yeah, right.
没有——是的，对，没错。
I love how these back to back ideas of, well, you should just not sleep around. And if you're going to sleep around, you should choose a bar girl, because we know she's a slut, so you're going to use a condom.
我喜欢这种背靠背的想法，嗯，你应该只是不要到处乱搞。如果你要到处乱搞，你应该选择一个酒吧女，因为我们知道她是荡妇，所以你会用避孕套。
There was one wonderful debate where somebody said, well, if we have to select partners, we should go with school girls, because they won't be infected. And then somebody else says, no, the school girls are all infected by the teachers. What you should really do is go for an ugly woman, because nobody else will have gone for her, so she's less likely to be infected.
曾有一个精彩的辩论，有人说，嗯，如果我们必须选择伴侣，我们应该选择女学生，因为她们不会被感染。然后有人说，不，女学生都被老师感染了。你真正应该做的是去找一个丑女人，因为没人会去找她，所以她被感染的可能性较小。
What surprised you the most when you started getting these back and reading through them, like stuff you just did not expect to see?
当你开始得到这些回信并读过它们时，什么最让你惊讶，比如你根本没预料到会看到的内容？
I had some expectations before hand, because I'd done a little bit of this in Kenya. So it wasn't quite as striking to me, the Malawi journals, as they would be to you. But the variety of places that people talked about AIDS. How, sometimes, it was just looking out the window. Somebody is on a bus, they look out a window, they see somebody thin, and the bus starts talking about it. Sometimes the bus driver gets into the story.
我事先有一些期望，因为我在肯尼亚做过一点这个。所以马拉维的日记对我来说不像对你那样惊人。但人们谈论艾滋病的地方非常多。有时，只是看看窗外。某人在公共汽车上，他们向窗外望去，看到某人很瘦，公共汽车上的人就开始谈论这件事。有时公共汽车司机会加入故事。
I had not really appreciated these group aggregate, like buses, people on a bus. And a lot of the things we learned, including this, were against the conventional wisdom. That people don't talk. They don't talk about sex. It's taboo. That they're fatalistic. Well, you can tell from these excerpts that they're not fatalistic.
我真的没意识到这些群体总量，比如公共汽车，公共汽车上的人。而我们学到的很多事情，包括这个，都是违背传统智慧的。人们不谈论。他们不谈论性。这是禁忌。他们是宿命论的。好吧，你可以从这些摘录中看出他们不是宿命论的。
Wait, so some of the prevailing thought was that people in these communities just assume they're going to get AIDS and die? So there's nothing they can do about it? That was the fatalism?
等等，所以一些主流想法是这些社区的人只是认为他们会得艾滋病并死去？所以他们无能为力？这就是宿命论？
Yeah, or another bit of the conventional wisdom was that they were in denial. They're just going on as if AIDS didn't exist. They don't want to believe it, so they don't believe it. But we see from the journals that they do believe it. And they do feel that they themselves are at risk. But then added to that-- and something that's not at all in the agenda of the prevention community-- is partner selection. And they advise each other to be careful. Before you select a partner, ask around, see what her behavior is, see who knows her.
是的，或者传统智慧的另一部分是他们处于否认状态。他们只是继续生活，好像艾滋病不存在一样。他们不想相信它，所以他们不相信。但我们从日记中看到他们确实相信。而且他们确实觉得自己处于危险之中。但随后除此之外——而且是一些预防社区议程中根本没有的事情——是伴侣选择。他们建议彼此要小心。在你选择伴侣之前，到处打听一下，看看她的行为是什么，看看谁认识她。
But has any of that prevailing wisdom that you've talked about, that you think is wrong, how is that then effecting prevention programs? If you start with that premise, then what did it mean about the programs?
但你谈到的那些你认为错误的传统智慧中，是否有任何一种正在影响预防计划？如果你从那个前提开始，那对项目意味着什么？
Well, it meant that they did some programs that weren't necessary. Because they were telling them to talk about AIDS when they were already talking about AIDS.
嗯，这意味着他们做了一些没必要的项目。因为他们在告诉他们谈论艾滋病，而他们已经在大谈艾滋病了。
Oh, so they were trying to encourage this kind of discussion, and you're saying it was already underway?
噢，所以他们试图鼓励这种讨论，而你说它已经在进行了？
It was already under way. Or they were trying to inform people that AIDS is here. Well, you've seen yourself, they've known that for a long time. So I think what that stuff did was justify spending money on things that, to be fair, the prevention community thought would be important, because they didn't know what was going on outside of their offices, basically.
它已经在进行中了。或者他们试图告知人们艾滋病就在这里。好吧，你自己也看到了，他们很久以前就知道这一点了。所以我认为这些东西证明了把钱花在那些事情上是合理的，公平地说，预防社区认为那会很重要，因为他们基本上不知道办公室之外发生了什么。
When you have talked about the contents of these journals and what they show, has the response changed? Has programming responded to your research?
当你谈论这些日记的内容以及它们展示的内容时，反应改变了吗？规划对你的研究做出了反应吗？
No. I don't think so.
没有。我不这么认为。
The problem, says Watkins, is that Malawi depends on outside money for AIDS prevention, big donors and NGOs. And so to make sure that money keeps coming, the Malawi government tailors its AIDS prevention strategies to whatever the international trends are. Even if those trends are based on assumptions about real Africans that aren't necessarily true.
沃特金斯说，问题在于马拉维依靠外部资金进行艾滋病预防，即大捐助者和非政府组织。所以为了确保资金持续注入，马拉维政府根据国际趋势调整其艾滋病预防策略。即使这些趋势是基于对真正的非洲人的不一定正确的假设。
You have to be sympathetic to somebody sitting in Washington, DC at the offices of USAID. How are they going to know what goes on? What they know, generally, about rural Malawians comes through the Malawian elites, largely, because those are the people they interact with.
你必须同情坐在华盛顿特区美国国际开发署办公室的某个人。他们怎么会知道发生了什么？他们通常所知的关于农村马拉维人的信息，很大程度上是通过马拉维精英传达的，因为那是他们互动的人群。
And they have very strong views. And so for the elites, AIDS is spread by people who aren't like us. AIDS is spread by superstitious, backward villagers. And AIDS is spread by sex workers. And AIDS is spread by sugar daddies. So there's some of these usual suspects. And even when there's very strong evidence against those, they just don't believe it.
而且他们有非常强烈的观点。所以对于精英们来说，艾滋病是由不像我们的人传播的。艾滋病是由迷信、落后的村民传播的。艾滋病是由性工作者传播的。艾滋病是由老少配的男人传播的。所以有些是这些通常的嫌疑人。即使有非常强有力的证据反对这些，他们就是不相信。
Let me give you an example. Where nobody ever says, the problem, the driver of the epidemic, is men with money. And yet the evidence shows, very clearly, that the highest prevalence is among the wealthiest and most educated men. I know. But when I suggest, well, why don't we go after the elite men? People just look at me like I'm totally nuts. I think it's just seen as an impossibility. It's seen as men's nature. So it's better to try to train women to negotiate condom use and to protect themselves than it is to pay any attention to the men.
让我给你举个例子。没人会说，这个问题，疫情的驱动因素，是有钱的男人。然而证据非常清楚地显示，最高流行率是在最富有和受过最高教育的男人中。我知道。但当我建议，嗯，为什么我们不去对付那些精英男人呢？人们只是看着我，好像我完全疯了。我认为这只是被视为不可能。这被视为男人的本性。所以尝试培训女性协商避孕套的使用并保护自己，比关注男人要好。
If it were up to her, she said, she spend every penny of AIDS prevention money on the one new thing that's been proved effective scientifically, that is on male circumcision. I can see the meeting now. The 72-year-old white woman sits down with Malawi's health minister, various other government and NGO officials in suits, and tells them, forget the prostitutes and bar girls. You  all need to go get yourselves circumcised. Good luck with that.
如果由她决定，她说，她会把艾滋病预防资金的每一分钱都花在已被科学证明有效的唯一新事物上，那就是男性包皮环切。我现在就能看到那个会议。72岁的白人妇女坐在马拉维卫生部长、其他政府和穿西装的非政府组织官员面前，告诉他们，忘了妓女和酒吧女吧。你们都需要去把自己包皮环切了。祝你们好运。
Susan Watkins is a professor at UPenn and a visiting research scientist at The California Center for Population Research at UCLA. The more than 1000 journals she's collected from Malawi are being catalogued now. You can read some of them on the website of her project. The link to that is on our website, thisamericanlife.org.
苏珊·沃特金斯是宾夕法尼亚大学的教授，也是加州大学洛杉矶分校加州人口研究中心的访问研究科学家。她从马拉维收集的1000多本日记现在正在编目中。你可以在她项目的网站上阅读其中的一些。链接在我们网站，thisamericanlife.org。
[MUSIC - "PEOPLE GONNA TALK" BY JAMES HUNTER]
[音乐 - 詹姆斯·亨特的 "PEOPLE GONNA TALK"]
Coming up, Leo likes Astrid, pass it on. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，里奥喜欢阿斯特丽德，传下去。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Sarah Koenig. Ira Glass is away, so I'm filling in as host. Today's show, gossip. An especially low form of gossip is backbiting, low, but entertaining. It's what we've been watching slack-jawed for the past decade on reality TV. It's the engine of a million plots, because it never runs dry, especially, if you make it up. Novelist Rebecca Makkai has this short story.
这是《美国生活》。我是莎拉·柯尼格。艾拉·格拉斯不在，所以我代班主持。今天的节目，八卦。一种特别低级的八卦是诋毁，低级，但很有趣。这是我们过去十年在现实电视节目中目瞪口呆地看着的东西。它是百万剧情的引擎，因为它永远不会枯竭，特别是如果你编造它。小说家丽贝卡·马凯有这个短篇故事。
Markus is a gifted crier. We just say, "Tell us how your grandfather would feel," and he gushes like Miss America. "My grandfather would be so proud of me," he says, and blows a kiss to the sky. Or we ask if he feels that his whole life has been a struggle? He says, "I just feel like my whole life has been just this huge struggle," and then he starts snorting and choking and holds up a finger.
马库斯是个有天赋的哭包。我们只需要说，“告诉我们你爷爷会怎么想，”他就涌出泪水像美国小姐一样。“我爷爷会为我感到骄傲的，”他说，并对着天空飞吻。或者我们问他是否觉得他的一生都是一种挣扎？他说，“我只是觉得我的一生就是一场巨大的挣扎，”然后他开始抽泣和哽咽，竖起一根手指。
The producers love the criers. And they love the cocky bastards. And they love the snarky gay men. The others we try to get drunk. We flirt with the straight guys, if there are any. If necessary, we feed them lines.
制片人喜欢哭包。他们喜欢自大的混蛋。他们喜欢尖酸刻薄的男同性恋。其他人我们试着灌醉。如果有直男的话，我们跟他们调情。如果必要，我们给他们台词。
I  don't try very hard anymore to explain to Beth what I do, why my voice is never on the show. Really, I think she's pretending to be confused. I think she likes saying, "OK, but why don't they just have the contestants talk to the camera on their own? Aren't they smart enough?"
我不再太努力向贝丝解释我做什么，为什么我的声音从不在节目中出现。真的，我想她在假装困惑。我想她喜欢说，“好，但为什么不让选手们自己对着摄像机说话呢？他们不够聪明吗？”
If I tried to tell her about Sabrina screaming at the judges, or Astrid getting drunk she says, "Don't tell. You'll ruin the show for me." Even though, half the time, she doesn't watch what I've worked on. And so I stopped talking, because what else could I possibly talk about.
如果我试着告诉她萨布丽娜对评委尖叫，或者阿斯特丽德喝醉了，她说，“别告诉我。你会毁了我的节目。”即使，一半的时间，她根本不看我做的东西。所以我不再说话了，因为我还能谈论什么呢。
Hour after hour, Inez and I sit, side by side, in folding chairs. The contestants sit on what looks like a throne, something oak and leather the producers found in the library. Inez is great at maintaining a lethally bored expression, so that whoever we're interviewing feels compelled to say more and more interesting things, more outrageous, more emotional.
一小时又一小时，伊内兹和我并排坐在折叠椅上。选手们坐在看起来像宝座的东西上，那是制片人在图书馆里发现的橡木和皮革制品。伊内兹非常擅长保持一种极其无聊的表情，这样无论我们采访谁，都会被迫说出越来越多有趣的话，更离谱、更情绪化。
We say, "We're not getting a character arc from you. This is going to be boring TV." We say, "Remember this is a job. We're paying you, and your job is to answer all the questions." Then we ask, "What do you hate about Leslie?"
我们说，“我们没从你这儿得到角色弧线。这会是无聊的电视节目。”我们说，“记住这是一份工作。我们在付钱给你，你的工作是回答所有问题。”然后我们问，“你讨厌莱斯利的什么？”
"I don't hate her," they say.
“我不讨厌她，”他们说。
"Yes, but you need to answer the question."
“是的，但你需要回答这个问题。”
"Well, she's pretty sure or herself. I mean she's good."
“嗯，她对自己很有把握。我是说她很好。”
We say, "That's great. Go with that. What does her confidence remind you of?"
我们说，“太好了。就那样说。她的自信让你想起了什么？”
"Like a gorilla? Like this big, silver-back gorilla that's bigger than you?"
“像大猩猩？像那种比你还大的大银背大猩猩？”
"That's what we're looking for," we say. "Now we need a full sentence about how you hate it."
“这就是我们寻找的，”我们说。“现在我们需要一个完整的句子关于你如何讨厌它。”
"Leslie's been swaggering around like some big, silver-back gorilla, like beating her chest, and telling everyone how great she is. It's driving me crazy."
“莱斯利一直像大银背大猩猩一样昂首阔步，拍打她的胸脯，告诉每个人她有多好。这让我快疯了。”
If you've ever seen Starving Artist , if you've ever even heard of it, you'r probably a gay man between 25 and 40. We gather artists from all different fields-- this season a painter, a dancer, a poet, a glass-blower, a playwright, a piano composer-- and stick them in an old, defunct, artists' colony in northern Pennsylvania for 25 days.
如果你看过《饥饿艺术家》，如果你甚至听说过它，你可能是一个25到40岁的男同性恋。我们聚集来自不同领域的艺术家——这一季有画家、舞者、诗人、吹玻璃工、剧作家、钢琴作曲家——把他们关在宾夕法尼亚北部一个废弃的艺术家聚居区25天。
We give them prompts. The first episode was nightmare, then Shakespeare, then baseball. They work for a day and a half, creating something small, and potentially beautiful, and always tragically rushed. And then they're judged, eliminated, given warnings, awarded prizes, the normal deal. The poor playwright got a 50 second performance limit on each play. He went home sobbing after the second elimination, twitching and covered in hives. The winner gets an agent and a $200,000 grant. The losers get publicity cut with humiliation.
我们给他们提示。第一集是噩梦，然后是莎士比亚，然后是棒球。他们工作一天半，创作出小的、可能很美的、总是匆忙的悲剧。然后他们被评判、淘汰、给予警告、颁发奖项，通常的做法。可怜的剧作家在每部戏上有50秒的表演限制。他在第二次淘汰后哭着回家，抽搐并浑身起风疹。获胜者得到一个代理人和20万美元的赠款。失败者得到羞辱带来的宣传。
I come home, upset about the playwright. And I try to tell Beth.
我回家后，为那位剧作家感到难过。我试着告诉贝丝。
She says, "But I thought the point for these people was the exposure?"
她说，“但我以为这些人是为了曝光率？”
I say, "I don't think that's what he even wanted."
我说，“我不认为那是他想要的。”
He wasn't typical. His name was Lincoln, and he seemed so surprised by everything, so constantly startled by the number of people, and by our lifting his shirt to re-tape his mic.
他并不典型。他的名字叫林肯，他似乎对一切都感到惊讶，对人数的多少，以及我们掀起他的衬衫重新贴麦克风感到不断惊吓。
"People are going to remember him as the twitchy-hive guy," I say, "and I don't think he'll even know how to take advantage of the publicity."
“人们会记得他是个抽搐起疹子的家伙，”我说，“我不认为他甚至知道如何利用这种宣传。”
"Then why did he sign up?"
“那他为什么要报名？”
Beth is knitting at the speed of light with tiny wooden needles. She's the kind of person who can undo a knot in any necklace and get a broken toaster to work again. That was how we met. We lived in the same building in LA. And when she looked out her second story window and saw me throwing a toaster in the dumpster, she called down that she bet me it was just the heating element. And she could fix the calibration with a flat-head screwdriver and a beer.
贝丝正用细小的木针以光速织东西。她是那种可以解开任何项链上的结，并能让坏掉的烤面包机再次工作的人。我们就是这样认识的。我们住在洛杉矶同一栋楼里。当她从二楼窗口看到我把烤面包机扔进垃圾箱时，她大喊着打赌那只是加热元件坏了。她能用平口螺丝刀和啤酒校准它。
Right now I shrug at her question. But I don't know why Lincoln signed up for the show. Optimism, I suppose, but I don't say that. And this is the way a lot of our conversations have been ending, one of us asking a question, the other not answering.
现在我对着她的问题耸耸肩。但我不知道林肯为什么报名参加节目。乐观，我想，但我没说出口。这就是我们很多对话的结局方式，一个问问题，另一个不回答。
Eight days in, the producers tell us we need a romance arc.
八天后，制片人告诉我们需要一条浪漫弧线。
Kenneth says, "It has to be Leo and Astrid, because she's the hottest girl, and he's the only straight guy. We have to go hetero on this." And then he says to me, "No offense, Christine. It's the network. They're asses, and they don't get our demographic at all."
肯尼斯说，“必须是里奥和阿斯特丽德，因为她是最好的女孩，而他是唯一的直男。我们必须在这方面走异性恋路线。”然后他对我说，“别介意，克里斯汀。这是电视网。他们是混蛋，他们根本不懂我们的受众。”
Inez says, "You expect us to make them fall in love?"
伊内兹说，“你指望我们让他们坠入爱河？”
He slurps his coffee through the lid and then looks at the ceiling, "Yep."
他从盖子里吸溜咖啡，然后看着天花板，“是的。”
The next time Astrid sits down, she's just escaped elimination. She's in that wonderful spot between ecstatic and vulnerable. She's the glass blower, and the judges are getting bored with her. I want to tell her she'll be safe if she can just pretend to love Leo, but I don't think she can act that well. So I say, "How do you feel about Leo being the only straight guy here?"
下一次阿斯特丽德坐下时，她刚刚逃脱淘汰。她处于那种狂喜和脆弱之间的美妙位置。她是吹玻璃工，评委们对她感到厌倦了。我想告诉她，如果她能假装爱上里奥，她就会安全，但我认为她演不了那么好。所以我说，“你觉得里奥是这里唯一的直男有什么感觉？”
Astrid has long blond hair with a pale-blue streak. Her nose is pierced and she's beautiful. If you saw her on the street, you'd think she was already famous.
阿斯特丽德留着长金发，有一条淡蓝色的挑染。她的鼻子穿了孔，她很美。如果你在街上看到她，你会认为她已经很有名了。
"I think Leo is getting along well with everyone. It's got to be hard being the only straight guy here," she says to the camera.
“我认为里奥和每个人都相处得很好。作为这里唯一的直男一定很困难，”她对着摄像机说。
Inez takes over, "Can you see anything happening between the two of you?"
伊内兹接过话头，“你能看到你们两人之间有什么发生吗？”
"I don't see anything happening between me and Leo," she says. But she's blushing, so we can use it. "He's cute, but I'm focusing on my art right now."
“我没看到我和里奥之间有什么发生，”她说。但她脸红了，所以我们可以用这个。“他很可爱，但我现在专注于我的艺术。”
I would have stopped there knowing we got, "He's cute," but Inez keeps going.
我会停在那儿，知道我们得到了，“他很可爱”，但伊内兹继续。
"What do you think about his flirting with you? Is it distracting you from the challenges?"
“你觉得他和你调情怎么样？这分散了你对挑战的注意力吗？”
Astrid tilts her head, and her hair falls down in waves. "I don't think he is."
阿斯特丽德歪着头，她的头发波浪般垂下。“我不觉得他在那样做。”
"But if he were, would that bother you?"
“但如果他在做，那会打扰你吗？”
"No."
“不。”
"Can you say it in a full sentence?"
“你能用完整的句子说出来吗？”
Astrid rolls her eyes. "It wouldn't bother me if Leo flirted." Bingo.
阿斯特丽德翻了个白眼。“如果里奥调情，那不会打扰我。”宾果。
We tell Leo, "So Astrid told us she thinks you're cute. She said, she wouldn't mind if you flirted a little."
我们告诉里奥，“所以阿斯特丽德告诉我们她觉得你很可爱。她说，她不介意你调情一点。”
There's a sudden wash of blood under his pale, freckled skin.
他苍白的、满是雀斑的皮肤下突然涌上一阵血色。
I say, "What do you like about Astrid?"
我说，“你喜欢阿斯特丽德的什么？”
"Astrid is a talented glass-blower. I think she's a real threat."
“阿斯特丽德是个天才的吹玻璃工。我认为她是个真正的威胁。”
"Do you think she likes your music?"
“你觉得她喜欢你的音乐吗？”
"I hope that Astrid likes my music." At least 90% of his blood is in his face now.
“我希望阿斯特丽德喜欢我的音乐。”现在至少90%的血液都在他的脸上了。
With a smile to let him know she's not really serious, but that she still expects an answer, Inez says, "A lot of viewers will be wondering if you're really gay. Are you?"
伊内兹带着微笑，让她知道她不是真的认真，但她仍然期待一个答案，“很多观众会想知道你是不是真的同性恋。你是吗？”
"I'm not gay. I'm attracted to women. There are a few cute girls here."
“我不是同性恋。我被女性吸引。这里有几个可爱的女孩。”
Inez looks triumphant. They'll use that last sentence over a shot of him awkwardly stepping aside to let Astrid pass in the dining room.
伊内兹看起来很得意。他们会把最后那句话用在餐厅里他尴尬地侧身让阿斯特丽德通过的镜头上。
Back at our little temporary apartment in town above the old lady's garage, Beth spends hours trying to figure out what she feels.
回到我们在镇上老太太车库上面临时租住的小公寓，贝丝花了几个小时试着弄清楚她的感受。
She'll start sentences this way, "It's just that sometimes, I think that maybe I feel like--"
她会这样开始句子，“只是有时，我想我可能觉得——”
I imagine her chasing her emotions with a stick-pin, trying to jab them into place before they get away again. They always get away again. All day long, while she's supposed to be designing websites, she sits on the couch writing in her journal, trying to decide if she wants to stay with me. Then when I get home, she reads me her journal. I tell her she'd give great interview. But really she wouldn't.
我想象她用别针追赶她的情绪，试图在它们逃跑之前把它们钉住。它们总是逃跑。一整天，当她应该在设计网页时，她坐在沙发上写日记，试着决定是否想和我待在一起。然后当我回家时，她读她的日记给我听。我告诉她她会是一个很好的采访对象。但真的她不会。
The camera doesn't have patience for someone who feels iffy, who weighs the options, who equivocates. And maybe that's why I want to throttle Beth when she tells me she's been making a list of the pros and cons, she says, of our relationship. I ignore this, and tell her how Inez and I are making two people fall in love.
摄像机对那些感到不确定、衡量选项、含糊其辞的人没有耐心。也许这就是为什么当贝丝告诉我她一直在列一份我们关系的优缺点的清单时，我想掐死她。我忽略了这一点，告诉她伊内兹和我正在让两个人坠入爱河。
"That's sick," she says.
“那很恶心，”她说。
Inez is mad that she can't flirt with Leo now. She says, "He was the only cute guy here."
伊内兹很生气她现在不能和里奥调情了。她说，“他是这里唯一可爱的家伙。”
She means out of everyone, the crew, the producers, the cast, and the entire population of Straithersburg, Pennsylvania where we've all flocked like refugees from LA and set-up camp. Kenneth tells us they have footage now of Leo and Astrid giggling in a hallway, choosing adjacent seats at the big dinner table, taking an early morning jog.
她的意思是所有人中，工作人员、制片人、演员，以及我们所有人像从洛杉矶来的难民一样涌入并扎营的宾夕法尼亚州斯特雷瑟斯堡的全部人口。肯尼斯告诉我们，他们现在有里奥和阿斯特丽德在走廊里咯咯笑，在餐桌旁选择相邻的座位，一起清晨慢跑的录像。
"My genius cupids," he calls us.
“我天才的丘比特，”他称呼我们。
I've done sleazier things every day for the past five years, but for some reason, this one is starting to feel wrong. Beth is getting to me maybe. Or maybe it's something about being outside of LA, here in the real world, where the normal rules of behavior should somehow apply.
在过去的五年里，我每天都做过更卑劣的事情，但由于某种原因，这一件开始让我觉得不对劲。也许是贝丝影响了我。或者也许是关于在洛杉矶之外，在这里的现实世界中，正常的行为规则应该以某种方式适用的事情。
Kenneth slaps me on the shoulder. "We're changing the next prompt to love. This should be good stuff, Christine."
肯尼斯拍了拍我的肩膀。“我们正在把下一个提示改为爱。这应该会是好素材，克里斯汀。”
When Astrid sits down in the interview chair, she asks if we can turn the cameras off.
当阿斯特丽德坐在采访椅上时，她问我们能不能关掉摄像机。
"Sure," we say. And give Blake, the camera guy, the signal to cover the red light, but keep taping.
“当然，”我们说。并给摄影师布莱克一个信号，遮住红灯，但继续拍摄。
She leans forward and says, "I know what you guys are trying to do with your questions about Leo. I get that you're supposed to create drama and everything but frankly this is insulting."
她前倾身体说，“我知道你们试图用关于里奥的问题做什么。我明白你们应该制造戏剧性之类的，但坦白说这很侮辱人。”
I look at Inez. "All we're doing," she says, "our role, is just to speed along what would happen in the real world if we had a lot more time. So let's say, in real life you know a guy and maybe after six months something starts to happen. OK, so here we don't have six months, we have two more weeks. And that's if you stay to the finale. We're not making you date him Astrid, we're just stirring the pot."
我看着伊内兹。“我们所做的，”她说，“我们的角色，只是加快如果时间充裕在现实世界中会发生的事情。所以，假设在现实生活中你认识一个家伙，也许六个月后发生了一些事。好，所以在这里我们没有六个月，我们还有两周。如果你坚持到决赛的话。我们不是强迫你和里奥约会，阿斯特丽德，我们只是搅局。”
"Well, I want you to stop," she says.
“好吧，我想要你们停下来，”她说。
"OK," I say, "sure." Although Inez is looking at me strangely. "Turn the camera back on Blake. Remember, present tense, full sentences. So Astrid, tell us about this week's prompt."
“好，”我说，“当然。”虽然伊内兹用奇怪的眼神看着我。“把摄像机打开，布莱克。记住，现在时，完整的句子。所以阿斯特丽德，告诉我们这周的提示。”
Inez and I take our only half hour off in five days to head out to the only coffee shop in Straithersburg.
伊内兹和我五天来第一次休息半小时，去斯特雷瑟斯堡唯一的咖啡店。
Inez says, "Why in the hell did you say we'd leave her alone? Tell me it's part of some master plan."
伊内兹说，“你为什么要说我们会放过她？告诉我这是什么宏大计划的一部分。”
I don't tell her that  I'm suddenly and deeply sick of messing with people. I say, "We need her on our side. She's not NPD."
我没告诉她我突然深切地厌倦了折腾别人。我说，“我们需要她在我们这边。她不是自恋人格障碍。”
The casting directors are great at spotting borderline narcissistic personality disorder, the kind that makes you just crazy enough for great TV but not crazy enough to destroy a camera with a baseball bat. The best casts are around 50% NPD but no more. Astrid was one of the contestants picked for her charisma and talent rather than her belief that she was destined to be famous.
选角导演非常擅长识别边缘性自恋人格障碍，那种让你疯狂到足以制作伟大的电视节目，但又不至于疯狂到用棒球棍毁掉摄像机。最好的演员阵容大约是50%的自恋人格障碍，但不会更多。阿斯特丽德是因为她的魅力和天赋被选中，而不是因为她相信自己命中注定要出名。
I say, "I see her really shutting down in interview if she thinks were manipulating her."
我说，“我看到如果她觉得我们在操纵她，她在采访中真的会关闭自己。”
"I'm just saying, Kenneth had very high hopes for the love challenge interviews."
“我只是说，肯尼斯对爱情挑战采访寄予厚望。”
"You can go to town on Leo then," I say. "Tell him she's pregnant with his child."
“那你去处理里奥吧，”我说。“告诉他她怀了他的孩子。”
Inez laughs, pretends I'm not annoying her. And we finish our lattes.
伊内兹笑了，假装我没惹恼她。我们喝完了拿铁。
As we walk up the endless grass hill to the colony, our shoes in our hands, Inez says, "You don't seem happy. Can I ask something?" she says. "Why exactly are you with Beth?"
当我们赤脚走过永无止境的草坡回到聚居区时，伊内兹说，“你看起来不快乐。我可以问个问题吗？”她说。“你到底为什么和贝丝在一起？”
The whole time we walk I'm tearing at my thumbnail and trying to answer her question, as if I'm a contestant and must answer the question. And must rephrase the question as part of the answer.
我们走的整个过程中，我一直在抠我的大拇指指甲，试着回答她的问题，好像我是选手，必须回答这个问题。而且必须把问题重新表述为答案的一部分。
I am with Beth because I've been fighting against her leaving for so long it's the only thing I know how to do. It's like that's my character arc. Like some producer has said, "We need you to be the quirky girl with the short hair who doesn't want her girlfriend to leave." And like the best contestants, the ones chosen for their compliance, I go along with it. Because what other role do I have?
我和贝丝在一起是因为我一直在反抗她离开，反抗了太久，这是我唯一知道怎么做的事。就好像那是我的角色弧线。好像某个制片人说过，“我们需要你成为那个留着短发、不希望女朋友离开的古怪女孩。”而且像最好的选手一样，那些因服从而被选中的人，我随波逐流。因为我还有什么角色呢？
Inez and I always listen in at the back of the judgment room so we don't have to get debriefed before the interviews. Kenneth is a genius. He lines the five remaining artists up in front of the book shelves where they'll be judged and then tells them we won't tape for a few more minutes, when really the cameras are already rolling.
伊内兹和我总是待在评判室后面偷听，这样我们就不必在采访前接受汇报。肯尼斯是个天才。他让剩下的五位艺术家排成一排站在书架前，他们将在那里受到评判，然后告诉他们我们还要等几分钟才录，其实摄像机已经在运转了。
He tells them to stand still for the light guys and then says, "We're having more digital issues. We're going to be here pretty late tonight folks."
他告诉他们站好给灯光师准备，然后说，“我们数字问题更多了。今晚我们要在这里待很晚，各位。”
And the sleep deprived artists, dehydrated and trying to hold still and awaiting judgment, give the most beautiful looks of disgust and despair. The cameras are getting it all. The editors will splice it in with shots of their work being critiqued or a competitor winning. They always fall for it.
而睡眠不足的艺术家们，脱水并试图保持不动，等待评判，给出了最美丽的厌恶和绝望的表情。摄像机抓住了这一切。剪辑师会将它们与他们的作品被批评或竞争对手获胜的镜头拼接在一起。他们总是上当。
Once Kenneth had one of the camera guys give all the contestants some incomprehensible direction in a thick accent while the other camera guys captured the grimaces of confusion. At the third judgment, he directed Inez to have a loud phone argument with a boyfriend in the corner of the room. That time we had enough snickering and eye rolling to manufacture an entire rivalry between Leo and Gordy. It became one of our best plotlines.
有一次，肯尼斯让摄像师之一用浓重的口音给所有选手一些不可理解的指导，同时其他摄像师捕捉他们困惑的鬼脸。第三次评判时，他指示伊内兹在房间角落和男朋友进行大声的电话争吵。那次我们有足够的窃笑和翻白眼来制造里奥和戈迪之间的整个竞争。它成为了我们最好的剧情线之一。
Even after all our work, by the end of the shoot Kenneth has decided to drop the love arc.
即使在我们所有工作之后，在拍摄结束时，肯尼斯决定放弃爱情弧线。
"We're way more into Leo's fallout with Gordy. And I think we'll want to paint Astrid as kind of a loner so that everyone roots for Sabrina," he says. "She's going to win."
“我们对里奥和戈迪的闹翻更感兴趣。而且我想我们想把阿斯特丽德描绘成一种孤独者，这样每个人都会支持萨布丽娜，”他说。“她会赢。”
They'll never use the beautiful footage of Leo blushing. Just like they'll throw away 99% of everything that happens. Those are the last four standing, beautiful Leo, Gordy the mediocre painter, Sabrina the shouter, and Astrid the blond.
他们永远不会用里奥脸红的美丽镜头。就像他们会扔掉发生的一切的99%。那是最后站着的四个人，美丽的里奥，平庸的画家戈迪，尖叫者萨布丽娜，金发的阿斯特丽德。
We have two more days left on the shoot. They'll be told that the final prompt is November. They'll go home to work on a portfolio of five pieces, preparing to come back before the judges and the almighty agent to present their work and make a case for their careers. They'll tell us all to love them, to care about their work, to see that they alone have embodied November.
我们拍摄还有两天。他们会被告知最终提示是十一月。他们会回家准备五个作品集，准备回到评委和全能的代理人面前展示他们的作品并为他们的职业生涯陈情。他们会告诉我们要爱他们，要关心他们的作品，要看到他们独自体现了十一月。
Of course, it won't actually be November. It's only June now. They'll have 10 weeks off, and then we'll shoot finale the last week of September. But it will air in late November, and that's all that counts. Not what time it is here, but what time it is on the other side of the TV screen.
当然，其实那不会是十一月。现在才六月。他们会有10周的休假，然后我们会在九月的最后一周拍摄结局。但它会在十一月下旬播出，而那才是最重要的。不是这里的时间，而是电视屏幕另一面的时间。
By the end I never see Beth awake. I don't know if we're broken up, if we're reconciled, or if we're the same as we always were. All I have is her unconscious body beside me in the dark when I get into bed and beside me, in the earliest gray light, when I roll out.
到最后，我从没看到贝丝醒着。我不知道我们是不是分手了，是不是和好了，还是我们和往常一样。我拥有的一切就是当我上床时，她在黑暗中无意识的身体，以及当我起身时，在最早的灰色光线下，她在旁边的身体。
On the last day of the shoot, I'm up in the house's attic searching among piles of abandoned furniture for a rug. I look out the window, down to the grounds, and there, back near the words, with no one else around, Leo and Astrid are kissing, passionately but slowly, like they've done it before. His hands in her hair, her hands in his back pockets.
拍摄最后一天，我在房子的阁楼里在废弃的家具堆里找地毯。我向窗外望去，向下看到地面，在那里，回到词汇附近，周围没有人，里奥和阿斯特丽德正在亲吻，充满激情但缓慢，好像他们以前做过一样。他的手在她的头发里，她的手在他的后裤兜里。
A giddy flood of adrenaline sends me halfway down the stairs on my way to tell Kenneth before I stop and think. Kenneth would love me for it forever . I could maybe get someone to lug a camera up the narrow stairs and shoot them before they walk away. I wonder, for a long time afterwards, why I don't. Instead, I walk back up the stairs. I lean against the window frame and watch them. It's a movie, and I'm the only one in the world with a ticket.
一阵眩晕的肾上腺素让我半路冲下楼梯，准备在停下来思考之前告诉肯尼斯。肯尼斯会永远因为这件事爱死我。我可能能让人拖着摄像机走上狭窄的楼梯，在他们走开前拍下他们。我在此后很长一段时间里都在想，为什么我没拍。相反，我走回楼梯。我靠在窗框上看着他们。这是一部电影，我是世界上唯一有票的人。
We shoot the artist's packing and leaving. We shoot them looking out the backseat window of a moving car. And then, suddenly, we're done. Instead of going home to Beth, I stay for the party. The camera guys do actual keg stands on the lawn. I won't miss this place at all. In September, Astrid, I think, will bring back delicate glass leaves and gray bubbles. Gordy will paint empty city streets. Sabrina will dance like an empty tree. Leo will play sad, beautiful, modern things on the piano that only I will know are for Astrid. And I'm certain that I will be coming back here alone.
我们拍摄艺术家打包离开。我们拍摄他们从移动汽车的后座窗口往外看。然后，突然，我们结束了。我没回家找贝丝，我留下来参加派对。摄像师们在草坪上进行实际的桶架投掷。我一点也不会想念这个地方。九月，我想，阿斯特丽德会带回精致的玻璃叶子和灰色的气泡。戈迪会画空荡荡的城市街道。萨布丽娜会像一颗空树一样跳舞。里奥会在钢琴上演奏悲伤、美丽、现代的东西，只有我会知道那是为阿斯特丽德准备的。而且我很确定我会独自回到这里。
Before the shoot starts, Inez and I and everyone lower on the totem pole, will run around making the place look like November, desolate and cold and fading. We'll stand on ladders to pull leaves off the trees. I've done it before. We'll spray some of the remaining leaves yellow, some red. We'll make everyone wear a coat. We'll kill the grass with herbicide.
拍摄开始前，伊内兹和我以及图腾柱底层的每个人，会四处跑，让这个地方看起来像十一月，凄凉、寒冷而褪色。我们会站在梯子上把树上的叶子摘下来。我以前做过。我们会把剩下的一些叶子喷成黄色，一些红色。我们会让每个人穿上外套。我们会用除草剂杀死草坪。
It's sick and it's soulless, but it's one of the things I love about my job. Here, you can force the world to be something it's not. We'll take the four contestants, one by one, into the foyer. And put them on that ridiculous chair and ask them, "Why do you deserve to win? How passionate do you feel? What do you love about your work? How much do you love your work? What is the sucker punch love that ruins us so completely? And can you say it in a full sentence."
这很恶心且没有灵魂，但这是我喜欢我的工作的事情之一。在这里，你可以强迫世界成为它本来不是的样子。我们会把四个选手一个接一个地带进门厅。让他们坐在那把可笑的椅子上，问他们，“你为什么值得赢？你觉得有多激情？你喜欢你的作品的什么？你有多爱你的作品？毁掉我们得如此彻底的“傻瓜一击”是什么？你能用一个完整的句子说出来吗。”
Rebecca Makkai is the author of the novel, The Borrower , which was just published in June.
丽贝卡·马凯是小说《借款人》的作者，该书刚在六月出版。
[MUSIC - "HE SAY, SHE SAY" BY SHOW & A.G.]
[音乐 - SHOW & A.G. 的 "HE SAY, SHE SAY"]
Our program was produced today by Ben Calhoun and me with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Miki Meek. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Music help from Damien Graef. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website.
我们的节目今天由本·卡尔霍恩和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。米基·米克提供制作帮助。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康顿是我们的办公室经理。达米安·格拉夫提供音乐帮助。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥韦茨负责我们的网站。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
WBEZ management oversight from our boss Mr. Torey Malatia. Who, when I told him Ira was away, finally saw his chance to get us to stop talking about him on the show.
WBEZ管理监督来自我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他，当我告诉他艾拉不在时，终于看到了机会，让我们停止在节目中谈论他。
It's just that like I don't really like people knowing my business.
只是我真的不喜欢别人知道我的私事。
I'm Sarah Koenig. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是莎拉·柯尼格。艾拉·格拉斯下周将回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI Public Radio International.
PRI 国际公共广播电台。